it's show time don't call it a comeback  there's something about a fully  immersive experience with sound and  visuals that I prefer over some kind of  like small TV experience enhances  everything cable a super soldier from  the future bring it on one eye really  has returned to the present to kill a  future killer who happens to be a boy  and Deadpool has some stakes in that  boy's future himself and the two clash  oh yeah your bullets they're really fast  man wipe it up yeah it's gonna be IMAX  is awesome as we all know especially in  big action scenes I mean IMAX is gonna  be a sight to behold IMAX is bigger  better badder you're no hero you're just  a clown dressed up as a toy so dark  you're not the DC Universe bigger  stronger faster  [Music]